the next president of France amanwe
makan former investment banker business
is celebrating his win under Michel
Europe's second largest economy will
remain in the EU McColl has pledged to
pull France out of its economic malaise
with a far-reaching reform programme he
plans to gradually liberalize the French
labor market youth unemployment is a
major problem a quarter of people under
25 are unemployed and without job
training in Germany by comparison the
youth unemployment rate is 6.7% but the
highest youth unemployment rate in
Europe is in Greece the next problem is
government debt which stands at 96
percent of GDP for years expenditure has
exceeded income macaws promised to
implement fiscal restraint and follow
Germany's example in reducing debt
there's a further challenge unlike
Germany France has a trade deficit
[Music]
the bottom line is that exports are too
low what spending on import is too high
macron solution is to reduce public debt
with cuts to public spending on health
and unemployment benefits the 39 year
old also has ambitious investment plans
he's proposed freeing up the funds by
selling off the state's holding in car
makers Renault and PSA group the
president-elect says he wants to spend
60 billion euros on forward-looking
economic policies this year reducing
youth unemployment and improving
qualification programs primarily in the
digital economy and the renewable energy
sector in the long run my crimes to make
France a stronger partner in the EU as
its neighbour Germany